ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويريع
الخبير العسكريه والاستراجي لواء فايز
قائد سلاح الجو الاوكرانيه يقول ان هذه
الطائرات لن تحل المشكله اذا ما الذي
ستقدمه
يعني هي لن تحل المشكله بصوره جذريه
ولكنها تقدم اضافه لا يمكن تجاهلها عندما
نتحدث عن 13 طائره من سلوفاكيا و4 طائرات
من بولندا نتحدث عن 17 شرطه
نتحدث عن رقم كبير التقرير جاء على عمليات
الخدمه اللوجستيه الطائرات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تشترك وفي معظم الايام هناك طلعات
للطائرات الاوكرانيه الفرق الرئيسي
29 تم تصنيع العديد من الاجيال يعني
الطائره التي قدمت الى سلوفاكيا ليست
مطابقه لما قدم لبولندا لرومانيا لبلغاريا
لاوكرانيا او حتى للجيش السوفيتي نزع منها
بعض الامور ولكن هذه الطائره هولندا
الاسلحه التي تقدمها او الطائرات التي
تقدمها تحمل صواريخ هارم ماذا يعني ذلك
في سياق المعارك بالطبع هذا ما كنت اود
العشاء هذا ما كنت اود الاشاره له انه هذه
الطائره
سلوفاكيه هي من طراز يو بي اس وهذا الطراز
تم اجراء تعديلات عليه يعني اتحدث عن
الطائرات التي تقدم من سلوفاكيا تم اجراء
تعديلات تتعلق في الكمبيوترات اصبح بها
اربع كمبيوترات بدل الكمبيوترات القديمه
مدى الرادار مئه كيلو متر الى الامام 45
كيلو متر الى الخلف وكذلك الطائرات التي
زودت على بولندا تم تجويدها بتسليح غربي
بينكيه لا بقيت على السلاح الروسي بدون
رغم كل ذلك رغم كل ذلك ورغم التحفظات
والحديث عنها بانها لا تقدم الكثير وستدمر
الايام ستثبت انها ستحدث نوع من الفرق
لماذا لانها تعتبر طائره تفوق جوي او
طائره الصف الامامي وعندما
تم تصنيعها صنعت لمواجهه الاف 16 عوده
خرسون الى تصدر المشهد من جديد بتقديرك ما
هي الاسباب
يعني انا اعتبره تصدر جزئي لماذا الحديث
عن محاوله بارجه انزال كتيبه الى الضفه
اليسرى من نار خرسون قد يكون لي تحفظ على
استخدام كلمه بارجه لان البارجه اصلا هي
ليست سفينه ابرار وهي ليست معده لانزال
قوات هي وسيله هي تعتبر
البارجه اكبر من المدمره تستخدم القوه
الناريه هي
سفينه قتال وليس ابرار ولكن انسجاما مع ما
تم الاعلان عنه لا اعتقد ان البرج تستطيع
حمل كتيبه انما وبالتالي يصبح كلمه كتيبه
مفهوم مطاط مفهوم مفتوح هي حمله جنود اذا
دعيني اقول هي قد تكون محاوله
جرع انتباه وتشتيت التركيز الروسي عن
بالنسبه لباقمت واجبارهم على تخفيض الضغط
على طاقموت ونقل جزء من القوات الى خرسن
لمواجهه تداعيات
اعتبرت مقدمتها هذه البارجه وعمليه محاوله
الان المهمه او الهدف لم تنجح اوكرانيا في
ذلك وفقا للجانب الروسي كيف يمكن ان يؤثر
ذلك على المعارك في باخمه
لهذا السبع ماذا قلت لك انه اتحفظ على
كلمه باريجي وعمليه الانسان لانها ليست
معده انزال لو كان هناك انزال حقيقي سيكون
مختلف هناك المعديات وهناك قطع بحريه
مخصصه لهذا الشيء وهناك لازم ان يجب ان
تكون نقاط عبور متعدده مما يوشي بحمله
عبور للنهر اذا هي عمليه لفت انتباه ليس
اكثر وبالتالي قد تنجح هذا النوع من
الخداع الاستراتيجي
حتى الان لا اقول انها نجحت هذا يعتمد على
رد الفعل الروسي لانه يجب ان ياخذ هذه
المحاوله بعين الاعتبار هل سيقوم بساحه
جزء من قواته من ام سيقوم باحضار قوات من
مناطق اخرى من ماريوبول او ميلتوبل او
غيرها وبالتالي انما تعتبر حدث جديد يلفت
الانتباه ويجب معالجته
فايز الدويريه الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان